My childhood traumas are not like yours
you see I'm a cursed Langmore
Hey guys, Pete here. I wanted to do a quick Ozark
season 4 part 2 video today because they did put
out a short teaser as a date announcement. there
isn't much here but I did like how they refocused
things back on Ruth you have this mystery of
the birds car accident that's hanging over the
final episodes the flash forward they opened the
season with that kind of takes over a lot of the
conversation about what's going to happen and this
is here to remind you that ruth is going to be
out for revenge after what happened to wyatt in my
last video i said i thought the release date would
likely be at the end of april and that turned out
to be true i thought it made the most sense and
yesterday we found out that ozark season 4 part 2
will drop on april 29th 2022 the remaining seven
episodes of the series will be available and
we'll learn how this story ends the teaser is
a mix of scenes some are from the first part that
we've already seen with some brand new ones mixed
in it has a voiceover from ruth which i think is
just recycled from season two but i suppose it's
possible she's reading this again and if you're
wondering where it came from this is the letter
wyatt wrote when he was trying to get into college
in the third episode of the second season ruth
came in and read it to him because she was worried
he wasn't taking it seriously and also because
it's dark if not plain sad or depressing i thought
this was a smart callback because there was a lot
of distance between these two characters in season
three and this relationship is so important in
defining who ruth is it underlines all that she's
lost since she decided to steal the byrde's money
back in season one and how the association with
marty and his family got us to where we are
heading into the ending of the story in voice over
we hear her read his words my childhood traumas
are not like yours you see i'm a cursed langmower
long in order to violence and death and in the
case of a langmore perhaps not soon enough there
are two lines that are omitted from this original
letter but the spirit is the same as far as what
we see in the teaser most of the early shots are
from part one we see wyatt at the trailer and
ruth driving away after discovering the bodies
there's a new one of crime tape on darlene's
front door and a shot of navarro in his jail
cell with his door opening nothing jumps out here
he looks like he's in the same jumpsuit that he
was wearing in the finale and you can see that his
hand still has the bandage on it so not much time
has probably passed there's a quick shot of hobby
smiling which i think is new although it's hard to
say what's going on he might be talking to claire
shaw here then there's one of the more interesting
shots this is the new character Camila Elizandro,
Omar Navarro's sister Javi's mother she's supposed
to play a large role in part two and in this shot
we see marty meeting with her in mexico another
interesting one has ruth turning on the light in
darlene's barn and there's a lot of dope packaged
up and ready to go it's been a question as to what
will happen to her property and her poppy farm and
i don't know if ruth would end up getting control
of those what i hadn't considered though was that
there may be a large amount of processed heroin
ready to go in that case what we see here someone
would have to get rid of all of that and this
would equate to a pretty substantial windfall of
cash for ruth this makes sense because who else
would be able to make this disappear that might
give her something to work with when she sets
out to go after hobby in the closing shot ruth
is looking at a handgun on the seat of her truck
and on the screen it says the end arrives sooner
than you think so it's an interesting tease but
it is just that a tease it's not a lot to go off
of like i said in my last video i am interested to
see how she goes after hobby what that looks like
i think the two new characters are the wild cards
chuck who we met briefly in part one and hobby's
mother camila it was nice to see a shot of her
and i'd be interested to see how you think these
two characters will factor into her plans and i
think that's about all there is to say here so
i'll leave it there let me know in the comments
what you thought about the teaser the release
date and how you're hoping the series will end
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon